Hello everybody, this is Dr. Kevin Cutters. We're going to talk about protein malnutrition
In this it will be a shorter video and there can be multiple reasons for protein
malnutrition and decrease protein in the bloodstream and and
Issues there's there's a lot of health issues with protein malnutrition with muscle loss and things like that
Usually you see protein malnutrition articles talking about
Third world countries where people are not getting enough food, but it's it's this is a common scenario with cancer patients
So we we definitely want to discuss it. This is an article from a research study in
2017 it talks about cancer patients
often experiencing weight loss so typically in
When a person is diagnosed with cancer, they may try to change their diet and clean up their diet and they can have a sudden weight loss because of that
Maybe they're shedding excess pounds
But when you're below your
Healthy weight, that's a concern and when you're continuing to lose weight after you've you know
Depressed below your healthy weight. That is a state of possible cacaxia
So cacaxia is when a person with later stage cancer is eating a lot of food or trying to eat a lot of food
Many times at that point in time they're not hungry. They can't eat maybe their
Their helper their spouses fixing meals for them. They only take a couple bites and they won't eat anymore and they're shedding
Several pounds per week. That's not a good state and you'll end up with a decrease in
Protein-a-protein malnutrition and protein as I've stated in other videos is so important in order to build
Your immune system so your cells your of your immune system that destroy cancer your natural killer cells and your T cells
Are dependent upon amino acids from your diet so if you're not eating enough protein
You're going to have a depressed immune response and if you're not eating enough food enough calories period
You can get into a state of cacaxia where you have weight loss
That's a very dangerous place to be and so
If you're you're watching this video and you're loved one is in that state
You want to really be encouraging them to eat
To the point of nagging them and I often say that on
Focals with people you know that I give the spouse the right to nag that person. They have got to eat
They got to get those calories in
It's a very dangerous state to be in when you're lower than your healthy body weight and you're continuing to lose weight
Well, you'll see some things on the bloods
Test with this you'll see a decreased blood urea nitrogen. You'll see a decreased creatine
um
Created in and that is commonly seen in any muscle wasting diseases. You can even see that with people
That are very strict vegans or doing a lot of fasted or
You know trying to diet going on strict diets or
People with eating disorders
You'll see a decreased total protein a decrease albumin and one of the things that you'll see with late-stage cancer patients
Especially as an elevated calcium to albumin ratio
It's often caused from an increase in blood calcium due to metastatic bone disease
combined with the decrease in
protein consumption
Decreasing albumin and so that ratio is very important. Make sure you work on your diet make sure you work on
hypochloridria issues
Make sure you watch that video as well
We don't want people in this state. So work at it before you get in this stage your estate
everything you can do
Just
continue to study and continue to
Learn and how to take care of yourself before you get in those critical states. All right. Thank you